Europe always struck me as a land full
of languages big ones like German and
Italian ones you may have never heard of
like Friulian or vim Monsieur ich gazing
over from the US it looks like a
linguistic playground ask the experts
though and you might get a different
view a grammatically flattered vanilla
uniform Europe where the languages share
common your reversals
it's the 1930s Benjamin Lee Whorf is
struggling to understand how the Hopi
talk about time
wait but hope he's not a European
language I know we'll get there
Worf is about to make a controversial
breakthrough the Hopi don't have
concepts for past present and future
he says because they speak Hopi we on
the other hand do see time this way
because we speak standard average
European and even if you've never set
foot in a linguistics class you've
likely heard part of this claim before
the concepts in your mind are relative
to the language you speak but I don't
see as many of you debating that second
part the standard average European I'm
here to change that so Worf let's say we
met a standard average European what
would they sound like
well not like any single language they'd
have common patterns that are
definitively European now early attempts
to listen for such patterns drew bold
conclusions from just a handful of
languages German French and English do
it so it must be European now depending
on which expert you trusted it started
to seem like any language in Europe both
was and was not standard average
European everyone felt like there was
some core heartland of shared European s
but they couldn't agree on specifics by
the 90s dissatisfied linguists were
demanding a more rigorous approach if
you can't find one make one so the
European Science foundation-funded euro
teep a huge project to collect data
about the typology of over 130 European
languages everything from word order to
tenses inflow of time to the
all-important adverbial subordinators
these are little words like because if
although the man responsible for
collecting these little words use them
to make general statements called euro
Versalles see the field of typology was
already hunting for universals things
true of every human language so here we
have your reversals about all european
languages if these make for some light
bedtime reading I promise
check out your reversal number one when
you have the time the hunt for your
Versalles didn't stop at grammar though
like in this more recent search for
widespread idioms where we discover that
shedding crocodile tears isn't unique to
English at least 45 languages in Europe
were found a fake their Sami
with the same turn of phrase but all of
these researchers admit we're still
lacking important data what's wrong with
our picture what are we still missing
well it's one thing to read your
reversal number one quite another when
the author goes on to say this could
just be a universal it's one thing to
find out that Europe cries crocodile
tears quite another when you learn the
same idiom appears in Swahili and
Mongolian if we want to know what makes
Europe unique we need to compare
non-european languages we got that
comparison in 2001 finally a serious
look at features pervasive in Europe but
uncommon around the world what was it
all arcane thorny grammatical nitpicks
actually most of it is straightforward
stuff here let's play a game called you
might be a European you might be a
European if you have a word for both D
and a you might be a European akyuu yous
have as a helping verb saying things
like have done and have seen you might
be a European if you use a little word
like then in comparisons you might be a
yeah sorry that got old but also if your
word for self is different from your
reflexive pronoun if you're an English
speaker these might sound normal enough
to make you shrug until you got to that
last one which works for German and
Spanish
but not English it's okay it's okay I
know nobody wants to hear their
languages less European than German what
if it is let's find out let's count
these features and score the languages
against each other
tallying and mapping the nine features
that have complete data we get a
geography of Year reversals
it's a bold and cohesive unit Germanic
languages Romance Slavic Baltic Greek
Hungarian Albanian all of them with five
or more features then it's a steep
drop-off down to languages that have
hardly any Maltese in the south
Basque and Celtic in the West Turkish
and Georgian in the East Finnish and
Estonian in the north we have our
boundaries but is there a core well
there is one area with a high
concentration of nine features right
here centered around France and Germany
dubbed the Charlemagne area now notice
that English is a couple notches outside
of that Charlemagne Corps despite being
a close relative of one of the languages
and a heavy borrower from another we've
been calling this standard average
European but it may not be so standard
or average on the world scene instead of
default it's actually been called
downright exotic
how do the continent end up sharing
exotic features and then convincing us
that these features were just plain
normal the answer would take up another
video and it's really just a bunch of
maybes maybe we can blame the migrations
and appeals of Middle Ages
perhaps the widespread use of Latin
maybe these languages have constantly
been adjusting to one another but one
thing's for sure the search for a
genetic route a shared ancestry behind
these features won't cut it
Europe's languages it seems aren't
exotically standard and average because
of what they've inherited but because of
what they've shared as they shape the
continent into a unique language area
well except maybe for you
Celtic and Basque hey stick around and
subscribe for language
[Music]
you